thank you very much indeed guy joined um
by peers um that press conference but
minutes away the news not unsuspected
not not unexpected but really really sad
my friend yeah I mean I just it's just a
shocking tragedy the whole thing and
I've been watching the coverage since
this debris uh turned out we're now
going to go live to the Coast Guard base
in Boston for a press conference about
what's happening
on the most recent findings from ROV
operations in search of the Titan
submersible he will provide a brief
statement and provide the opportunity of
her questions after please limit your
questions to one per Outlet
following the briefing the joint
information center staff and I will be
here to help you with any of your
further needs may I now please introduce
rear Admiral John mauger
this morning
an ROV a remote operated vehicle
from The Vessel Horizon Arctic
discovered the tail cone of the Titan
submersible approximately 1600 feet
from the bow of the Titanic on the sea
floor
the ROV subsequently
found additional debris
in consultation with experts from within
the unified command the debris is
consistent with the catastrophic loss
of the pressure chamber
upon this determination we immediately
notified the families
on behalf of the United States Coast
Guard and the entire unified command
I offer my deepest condolences to the
families
I Can Only Imagine
what this has been like for them
and I hope that this discovery
provides
some soulless during this difficult time
additionally we've been in close contact
with the British and French consul
General
to ensure that they are fully apprised
and that their concerns are being
addressed
the outpouring of support in this highly
complex search operation has been robust
and immensely appreciated
we are grateful for the rapid
mobilization of experts on the undersea
search and rescue and we thank all of
the agencies and personnel
for their role in the response
we're also incredibly grateful for this
full spectrum of international
assistance that's been provided
the rovs will remain on scene and
continue to gather information
again
our most heartfelt condolences
go out to the loved ones of the crew
will now take questions
experience
this was a uh incredibly complex case
uh and we're still working to develop
the details uh for the timeline involved
with this casualty and uh the response
and so we'll provide that information
so this is an incredibly complex uh
operating environment on the sea floor
over two miles beneath the surface and
so uh the the remote operating vehicle
has been searching and it is highly
capable and we've been able to classify
uh parts of the pressure chamber for the
Titan submersible let me refer to one of
my undersea experts here Mr Paul hankin
to talk about uh the nature of some of
the debris
thank you Admiral
so essentially we found uh five
different major pieces of of debris that
uh
told us that it was the
remains of the Titan the initial thing
we found was the nose cone which was
outside of the pressure Hall
we then found a large debris field
within that large debris field
we found
the the front end Bell of the pressure
hole
that was a first indication that
there was a catastrophic event
shortly thereafter we found the
a second smaller debris field within
that debris field we found
the the other end of the pressure hole
the the AFT and Bell
um
which was basically the comprised that
the totality of that pressure vessel we
continue to map the debris field and as
the Admiral said we will uh
do the best we can to
fully map out what's down there
so so the questions was related I'm
restating the question from the
standpoint of uh sometimes it's hard to
hear the question here uh what are the
prospects for re uh recovering uh crew
members and so uh this is a incredibly
unforgiving uh environment down there uh
on the sea floor uh and uh the debris is
consistent with a catastrophic uh uh
implosion of the vessel and so uh we'll
continue to work and continue to search
the area uh down there but uh I I don't
have an answer for uh prospects at this
time
sorry any suggestion at all that the the
sub itself collided with the wreckage of
Titanic or that instead of instead it
might have uploaded uploaded above the
wreckage and then rain down nearby
so the question was is there any
question as to whether or not the sub
collided with the Titanic or whether it
imploded uh above and debris uh field
created from that uh so the uh the the
location of the Titan submersible was in
an area that was approximately 1600 feet
uh from uh the uh wreck of the Titanic
uh I have an expert here that can that
is familiar with that area and can talk
about uh the debris field and and what
uh the debris field indicates in terms
of uh the where the casualty may have
occurred
thank you Admiral uh so the question is
where does the wreck lie in relation to
the Titanic uh I didn't hear the
Admirals uh answer I think 1600 feet was
that correct uh so that's uh that's off
the bow of Titanic it's in an area where
there is not any debris of Titanic it is
a smooth bottom uh there to my knowledge
and anything I've seen there's no
Titanic wreckage in that area and again
200 plus meters from the bow uh and
consistent with the location of last
communication for an implosion in the
water column and the size of the debris
field is uh consistent with that
implosion in the water column
in terms of the time
the time say that is what
this was right at the moment
so the question was about the timing of
the catastrophic implosion uh right now
it is uh too early to tell uh with that
uh we know that as we've been
Prosecuting uh this search uh over the
course of the last uh 72 hours uh and
and beyond that we've had sonar buoys in
the water nearly continuously and have
not detected any uh catastrophic events
uh when those sonar buoys have been in
the water so
and you describe what happens from here
sir in the next days and weeks in terms
of finding in
what happens from here
from here so we will uh the question was
uh what happens from here uh what What's
the next phase
um and so right now again our uh
thoughts are with the families uh and
making sure that uh they have uh
um an understanding as best as we can
provide uh
of of uh what happened and and uh begin
to find some closure uh in terms of the
large process we're going to continue to
uh
investigate the site of the debris field
uh and then I know that there's also a
lot of questions about uh how why and
when uh did this happen
um and so uh you know those are
questions that uh we will collect as
much information as we can on uh now uh
while uh the governments are are meeting
and And discussing uh you know what uh
uh an investigation of this nature of a
casualty might look like this is
something that happened I'll just just
remind everybody this is something that
happened in a remote portion of the of
the ocean uh with uh people uh from you
know several different countries around
the world uh and so it is a complex case
to work through but I I'm confident that
those questions will be begin to get
answered
the the question was uh was there any
suggestion that uh time factors uh may
have uh played a a
um a role or or a consideration in uh
the the casualty here and so the debris
field is consistent with a catastrophic
uh implosion of the vessel uh again
while we were Prosecuting the search we
had listening devices uh in the water
throughout and did not hear uh any uh
signs of catastrophic uh failure from
those and so we're going to continue to
investigate uh or we're going to
continue to document the information
there and and understand uh based on all
the information we have the the timeline
thank you
so the question was what uh what are the
resources required for the investigation
and which ships will be pulling out and
uh staying in and so uh it it's too
early uh for me to talk about an
investigation that's a decision that's
going to be taken outside of uh the
search and and uh efforts that I was
leading uh and but we do have a number
of vessels we have nine vessels on the
scene right now we had medical uh
Personnel on scene we had other
technicians on scene and so we will
begin to demobilize uh personnel and and
vessels from the scene uh over the
course of the next uh 24 hours but we're
going to continue uh remote operations
on the sea floor uh and and I don't have
a timeline for when we would intend to
stop remote operations on the seafloor
at this point
I think there's me changes in the way
these are safety rated or inspected so
that this won't happen again yeah the
question was essentially about do you
think that there should be changes in
safety ratings or inspection for these
standards uh
I know that there's a lot of questions
about why how when uh this happened and
and the members of the unified command
you know have those questions too as as
professionals and experts that work uh
in this environment and this is an an
incredibly uh difficult and dangerous
environment to work in out there but
those those questions about uh the uh
regulations that apply and and the
standards that's going to be I'm sure
focus of future review right now we're
focused on documenting uh the the scene
and continuing the the subfloor
account
so throughout the search efforts we
reacted to the information that we had
available to us and while we continue to
send it off for deeper analysis again
really complex uh operating environment
for us to work in uh
let me check with the experts but there
doesn't appear to be any uh connection
between the noises and uh the location
uh on the seafloor again this uh was a
catastrophic implosion of the vessel
which would have generated a significant
Broadband sound uh down there that the
Sono buoys would have picked up this
will be the last question
but also were all of the assets involved
as swiftly as possible to the area
this was a uh incredibly uh complex
operation uh and uh we were able to
mobilize an immense amount of gear uh to
the site and uh just a really remarkable
amount of time uh given the fact that we
started without any sort of vessel
response plan for this or any sort of
pre-stage resources and so the equipment
that was brought on site this morning
that we were using was a pelagic ROV uh
capable of operating at 6 000 meters uh
cameras sonar other uh articulating arms
and and resources on it and it's uh you
know we had to transport it here through
C-17 aircraft this is two aircraft that
it took to get this up here and so we've
really had the the right gear on site
and worked as uh as as swiftly as
possible to bring all of the
capabilities that we had to Bear uh to
this search and rescue effort uh and it
was just a huge uh International and
interagency effort to make this happen
so I'm I'm really grateful for all of uh
the responders that came out to support
this uh and and really uh you know
search uh for uh for the vessel it is a
difficult day for all of us
um and and it's especially difficult uh
for the families and our thoughts are
with the families today
um but this was an immense uh support
and we had the right gear on the bottom
uh to to find him so thank you
well that was the breaking news the
press conference there from the U.S
Coast Guard or does this seem to
remember John mulga he's the commander
of the U.S Coast Guard there uh
expressing his uh deep sadness over what
had happened and confirming the very sad
news that the five people on board the
Titans submersible have all uh perished
in this tragedy as Stockton Ross shazada
Darwood and his son Suleiman Darwin
Hamish Harding of course the British
billionaire and Paul Henry nargely
they're all now confirmed to have died
and it appears that the Titans suffered
a catastrophic implosion due to the loss
of pressure in the chamber and
fragmented it seems about 1600 feet away
from the wreckage of the Titanic so some
way down towards the the wreckage but
not actually there itself but some very
powerful
words there from the rear admirables
saying these men well this is first of
all a statement from Ocean Gate or the
company of course who uh who put on this
trip and owned the Titan they said we
now believe that I see a Stockton rush
and the other on board has sadly been
lost these men were true explorers who
shared a distinct Spirit of adventure
and a deep passion for exploring and
protecting the world's oceans our hearts
are with these five souls and every
member of their families during this
tragic time we grieve the loss of life
and joy they brought to everyone they
knew this is an extremely sad time for
our dedicated employees who are
exhausted and grieving deeply over this
loss so what we know now is the side of
the fatal accident was 1600 feet so 487
meters off the bow of the Titanic wreck
the authorities found five major pieces
of debris these apparently included a
nose cone the front end of the pressure
Hull and the back end of the pressure
Hull this is confirmed by Paul Hankins a
salvage expert for the U.S Navy he said
that these pieces indicated there have
been a catastrophic event of an
implosion so it had imploded rather than
exploded all families were immediately
notified this was discovered this debris
around half past two three o'clock UK
time and he has said that the chances of
recovering the bodies according to real
Admiral morga is very slim because it's
an incredibly unforgiving environment so
it's not been ruled out but clearly from
what he said there it has to be unlikely
um he said it's too hard to tell exactly
when the implosion had taken place but
they do know now for sure that there was
a catastrophic implosion that sadly
killed everybody on board well I'm
joined now rejoined in fact by guest I
had last night Fred Hagan who was on
board the last two Titan missions and
those two of the people on board
Stockton rush and Paul Henry najalay
well uh Fred I'm really sad to speak to
you again
now that we know the news which I think
we both probably feared yesterday we
didn't want to say that very sadly
everyone on board has lost their lives
what is your reaction to what we just
heard
what appearance as you can imagine
sitting here listening to this press
conference while waiting to talk to you
is uh
made this much more difficult than I
anticipated
and
I can normally say that
the world has lost two radiant points of
Life of light with
Stockton and pH
and as we talked yesterday
these men were great men who tried
greatly and risked everything
and I want their Epitaph to be what
Teddy Roosevelt said but
the credit belongs to the man who was
actually in the arena
whose face is marked by dust and sweat
and blood and just drives value errors
who come to short again and again
because there is no effort without our
shortcoming but who does actually strive
to do the Deeds who knows great
enthusiasms
the great devotions who spends himself
in a worthy cause
what the best knows in the end the
Triumph of high achievement excuse me
and who at the worst if he fails at
least fails well daring greatly
so the display shall never be
with those cold intimid Souls who know
neither victory
nor defeat and that to me
is the true Epitaph to stop from Rush
and phns delay and their Companions and
I'm very sorry I just
it it was just devastating sitting here
listening to the realization of what we
all feared and then trying to express my
feelings moments later I apologize Fred
there's no apology obviously needed at
all I know from my our conversation
yesterday how personally moved you've
been by this the rest of the world has
watched on in sort of mounting horror as
this story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal you've been on this
vessel you've been on the last two
Titanic missions in 2021 and 22 with
Stockton Rush with your friend pH he'd
been down to that wreckage 30 odd times
I think and brought back so many
extraordinary things for the world to
see it was a genuine historian in that
sense
um looking at a picture of of you all
now
um it's a desperately sad time for you
and for everyone who knew them their
friends their families everyone and it's
a sad time I think for the world to look
on and see people who ultimately as I I
said yesterday I got very angry about
the reaction
from certain people about the fact that
they were wealthy people paying to go
down there and so on it to me they were
Intrepid explorers doesn't matter how
much money you have they're Intrepid
explorers and some are paid to be there
and some were being paid to be there
makes the difference that the goal was
to go down and find
new information which could shed light
on one of the great tragedies of the
history of this planet which was the the
sinking of the Titanic and I commend
them for the courage that it took to do
that and I think that their death is an
absolute tragedy but they should be
remembered as Heroes who who went down
there I wouldn't go down there I mean I
I admire you for doing it you know it's
an extraordinary thing to want to do
and Piers yeah I'd like to say that
right now at this point in time
the death toll from the Titanic tragedy
has risen from 1517.
to 1522 and may God Rest their souls
yeah I mean it is an eerie thing isn't
it when you think about the Titanic and
the huge death loss as you say and the
fact that we're going down there to see
there and have now lost their lives it
was a very poignant interview actually
with the older sister of shazada Darwood
who said uh she felt absolutely
heartbroken that both her brother and of
course her nephews only 19 is a student
at strathclyde University
um and this is asthma Darwin who was the
aunt of that young boy and the sister of
of his father on board as well I feel
like I've been caught in a really bad
film she said with a countdown but you
didn't know what you're counting down to
I've personally found it incredibly
difficult to breathe thinking of them
she then said that her nephew didn't
want to go on the uh on the submersible
but agreed to take part because it was
important to his father a lifelong
Titanic obsessive uh the Solomon she
said wasn't very up for it and was
terrified explaining the 19 year old had
expressed his concerns on the Family
remember but that is of course part of I
guess the adventure and yes it's ended
it's ended in appalling circumstances
it's cost that young man his life but
his father obviously was enthralled by
the history of this and wanted to be
part of that history and to go down
there and to explore and again I say I
think it's a heroic and Noble thing to
do that kind of thing most people don't
get the chance to do it and don't have
the inclination to do it
most people live lives of quiet
desperation and these men lived large
they realize their dreams they pursued
them and they should be celebrated
it's been revealed by the Coast Guard it
doesn't appear to be any connection
between the underwater banging noises
that were identified yesterday coming
every 30 minutes and the location of
where this debris was found so they seem
to be same it doesn't appear to be any
connection there does that suggest to
you Fred that this catastrophic
implosion may have happened quite
quickly after they went down what would
be your reading of this
well clearly it happened very quickly I
was originally critical
of the fact that the those in command
did not allow the Brits to immediately
mobilize the Magellan and obviously that
was because they'd heard a seismic event
and they interpreted it as a
catastrophic failure and then those
noises were heard and there was a change
of heart the French came last night they
showed up on site for their beloved pH
and you know I believe that the Magellan
was finally mobilized and that was as a
result of hearing those knocking noises
but yes at this point uh clearly there
was a catastrophic failure on The
Descent and the and while we're all
devastated by the loss of these
wonderful human beings at the same time
there's another little part of me that
that is relieved that they have not
spent the last several days dying slowly
and the most horrific nightmares
condition yes I think that's absolutely
right uh it was from what I've read when
this kind of implosion occurs it
literally takes milliseconds and nobody
on board would even be aware of it
um it is catastrophic and instant
that is correct and at least they were
spared any suffering and that is some
solace
two ph's daughter and to the families to
Stockton's Widow Wendy and to all the
others I didn't know the other
passengers but it is a small solace
you know you talk about pH as
extraordinary man he served in the
French Navy for 25 years he was known as
Titanic's greatest Explorer according to
his biography he was widely considered
the leading Authority on the Titanic
shipwreck
um what was he like as a man Fred
well you were never known that he was
the preeminent deep diving expert on
Earth you know he was a continent
professional
but you would sit down with him and he
would be just as warm and relaxed as as
your oldest friend and as someone else
said whether he was just as comfortable
in the deck of a ship than a tornado as
he was sitting in a Parisian Cafe I mean
that was very true and and that was pH
he was very down to earth he was both
incredibly accomplished and Incredibly
humble
the
you've been on this you've been on the
same missions did you have moments Fred
were you felt unnerved scared even I
mean how intimidating is the experience
of doing this kind of Journey
it can be very intimidating
pH would would always be calm and and
you know there are some people that are
just calm under stress and I like to
think I'm one of them there were a few
moments we when we got kind of the
currents pulled us into the ship and we
were momentarily entangled and I I know
that others on the sub were
maybe more on nerved than you know and
they wanted to immediately Ascend for my
part uh you know we I was wanted I
wanted to see the stern and one of the
experiences I had this years we went all
around the bow and explored it and I
wanted to go to the stern on the Saint I
want to be the first person to see both
pieces on the same deck and we tried and
the when we got back Wendy and Stockton
were both incredulous and saying what on
Earth were you doing why were you trying
to get to the stern and of course I was
blamed for the our perseverance so I'm
not sure if I answered your question or
addressed it but yes there were moments
but they did not in any way
diminish my appetite to experience
the Titanic and experience this
wonderful adventure with with ph and
Argyle and I always treasure that event
and always treasure his friendship
we have a statement just in from the
British foreign secretary James
cleverley tragic news that those on the
Titan submersible including three
British citizens have been lost
following an international search
operation the UK government is closely
supporting the families affected and
expresses our deepest condolences
um Stockton Rush
inevitably I guess as the CEO and
founder of Ocean Gate he's come under in
the last few days a lot of criticism
along with the company uh for maybe
cutting corners and not doing enough
um to make the Titan properly secure for
this kind of mission
you know it's it I I don't think we
should labor that point now that he's so
sadly lost his life but what is your
response Fred to that particular
criticism that it wasn't really ready to
do this kind of thing
the only criminal act
was the failure of governments to
properly fund science and deep water
exploration
what Stockton did was to pursue Cutting
Edge technology to take human beings
into a realm where they've never gone
before
you know you've had previously you had
government funded submersibles maybe
that whole one or two people that have
gone that deep you've never had anyone
try to democratize the deaths trying to
take Humanity where it never belonged
and was never able to access and I I
look at it kind of like the original
Flyers as I mentioned previously the
Wright brothers took off and left the
Surly Bonds of Earth do you know how
many people died trying to make Aviation
safe and and where anybody could
participate safely they died by the
hundreds by the scores and they gave
their lives trying to you know stretch
the envelope to exceed expectations to
go further and farther and faster and
Stockton was doing that he was doing it
in the depths of the ocean which is the
great Frontier on Earth the last
unexplored region of Earth which is so
critical to our own future and critical
to the preservation of Life on her and
hey Miss Holland and I'll just
I'll just add that a lot of the
criticism that's mounting up I mean I I
hear things I've heard I can't tell how
many times I've heard about the joystick
it's a video game joystick and it's a uh
that's funny and people laugh and they
make fun of it well that's the
difference between a government-funded
project and a brilliant entrepreneur who
is trying to push boundaries the
government
would have spent tens of millions of
dollars designing a Jewish dick that
would have worked perfectly and
brilliantly Stockton Rush was able to
find a joystick that worked just as
efficiently by using a video game
controller and one thing I know beyond
any doubt is whatever happened to that
submersible it had nothing to do with
the video game controller
Fred I'm so sorry that this this has
ended the way it has a few or two great
friends it's a very sad day I think for
everyone who's ever been down on that
expedition to the Titanic and to lose
people who've so experienced so attached
to that must be a huge loss to you both
professionally I guess and also
obviously personally and I really
appreciate you joining me so soon after
that news was broken
thank you piers and I'll say again thank
you so much for your attitude and for
your gracious handling of this tragedy a
deeply deeply appreciate it and I know
the family does too well thank you Fred
and I I mean it I'm sincere about that I
think these people are heroic when they
do this kind of thing and to attack them
attack them because of how much money
they may have is completely missing the
point to me uh Fred Hagin thank you very
much indeed
thank you well just to recap for viewers
who are tuning in the very sad breaking
news that the Titan submersible which
had been missing for three days down the
wreckage of the Titanic sadly so it's
now transpired suffered a catastrophic
implosion we don't know exactly when
that happened but debris from The Vessel
was discovered at about 2 30 p.m UK time
this afternoon uh just before 9 A.M
eastern time in America uh they
discovered a series of items from the
debris which were identifiable as coming
from the Titan including a nose cone the
front end of the pressure Hull the back
end of the pressure Hull which made it
clear this was indeed the missing vessel
and very sadly that also meant that all
five of the people on board had lost
their lives so a very sad end to a story
which has gripped the world I'm joined
Now by someone who knows all about the
Perils of the ocean Rob O'Neill the
former Navy SEAL who was on many
missions including of course he was the
man who shot and killed Osama Bin Laden
Rob great to speak to you
um what was your reaction when you first
heard about what had happened here
my initial reaction to this was uh
because there was no last
like serious Communications where they
said hey we might have a minor issue
we're going to try this there was an
incident in 1963 with the USS Thresher
in April of 63 where they were doing
test dive to certain depths and there's
a design depth and a crush depth and
they were testing it and one of the
things that said they were experiencing
a leak and they said hey we're going to
try this on the on the uh the phone that
works the in the in the water and then
the next communication was you could
hear the metal
um clinking meaning they were getting
they got crushed and the only good thing
if it's not good but the only relief is
that it happened so fast at those depths
that you never know that it happened but
with this it wasn't I I would hope it
wasn't just a matter of it's either this
or nothing there's going to be a release
of a buoy with some sort of trans
transponder that can that can um
they could pick you up or find you and
there's going to be Communications this
they just this just they stop
communicating which means they got to a
certain depth and then it just crushed
them which uh
you know it's this isn't it's not a good
situation no matter what but if you're
going to die doing something you love
something
um the uh just exploring the way they
were which is how we get great
inventions I personally would rather it
be to get crushed that quickly than to
sit on the bottom and either run out of
air or freeze to death so I mean of all
the worst case scenarios that was the
best worst case and you know these five
people you can read all the crap on the
internet they're doing something that
this is these are innovators this is how
we get the good stuff people like this
do things like that like the Wright
brothers just to explore different
places like that we know more about
space than we do about the bottom of our
own oceans so I mean to me these are
these are Trailblazers and and um
it's a tough dad I normally peers like
to talk to you under different
circumstances this is tough uh it's it's
nice that there's closure it's nice that
we don't wonder if they're out there
suffering on the surface or down at the
subsurface but you know it's tough day
it's a very tough day and you more than
most people understand the inherent
danger of the ocean as well as the
excitement and the fun it's dangerous
isn't it and particularly when you're
diving at Great depth or going down the
vessel at Great depth
even if even if you're not diving at
Great depths there's so much science
there's so much physics and medicine
that comes into going subsurface because
every uh every 33 feet is one atmosphere
of pressure and you're dealing with
everything like uh like Boyle's Law how
pressure and and volume
um they're different and the further you
go down breathing
um uh compressed gases you can't come up
too fast because you're dealing with all
this stuff uh the lowest I've ever been
underwater while I was scuba diving was
150 feet which is a 15 story building
that is dark down there and it's scary
down there and the more you get into
mother ocean the more you realize that
yeah she takes care of the planet but
she's unforgiving and you know just like
a bullet the ocean needs to be right one
time and that's all it takes you need to
have respect for the ocean I love the
ocean the ocean is the reason we are who
we are and there's all you know but it's
everything from just you know when you
dip your toe in the ocean you're now at
the bottom of the food chain there are
predators in the ocean there's dangers
in the ocean there's science in the
ocean there's there's dark and there's
cold uh which tells you about these in
these five
um explorers they were willing to then
they signed the waiver saying we're
willing to do this yes and that that to
me is just that I think it's it's it'd
be hard to put your signature on that
line they had the guts to do that let
alone get in the sub and go down some I
mean my hat's off to him yeah I
completely agree I I I they I think
there were three warnings that you could
die doing this and they still all went
down there having signed those waivers
and that takes incredible courage uh
whatever but think of it and I I think
they are heroic for doing it uh Rob as
always it's great to talk to you I wish
it had been a happier ending to this
story it's a very sad day for anyone
who's ever been involved in oceanography
and particularly of course history of
the Titanic and everything that goes
with that so thank you very much
anytime thanks for having me I
appreciate it well Josh Gates the host
of expedition unknown joins me now uh
Josh thank you very much indeed for
joining me you actually walked away from
an opportunity to film the Titanic down
uh where it lurks in the ocean why was
that
well we uh we were thinking about doing
a special on Titanic and uh to work
alongside Stockton and Ocean Gate and we
went up to the Ocean Gate headquarters
in Everett Washington in 2021 so this
was just a few months before uh Ocean
Gate was set to take its first group of
passengers down to the Titanic and we
spent a few days up there and we went
out on Titan in Puget Sound and took it
out for what was effectively a Shakedown
dive getting it ready uh for those uh
operations in the North Atlantic and uh
you know by the end of my time there and
uh I had a real you know a terrific time
working with Stockton I'm absolutely
kind of just beside myself here
listening to all this just kind of
taking it in in real time it's just um
it's a lot to process but by the end of
that experience I just did not feel that
this was for me I I really felt more
than anything that it was nearly
impossible to to measure the risk of
Titan as a platform it was just almost
impossible to measure it against
anything else it is such a unique
vehicle it is a one-off you know there's
nothing else like it and because of that
there's nothing to compare it to and for
me it represented uh frankly just too
much risk and I and it just wasn't for
me in the end do you feel that but for
the grace of God
about this yeah I mean it's yeah you
know um I I knew Stockton and again I I
really am just stunned sitting here
about this news I knew Hamish Harding as
well who's a fellow member of the
Explorers Club an incredible individual
um a big figure both inside and outside
the club and and um
yeah I mean I'm beside myself there's
something uh I just sit here listening
to this news and remember my time in
Titan remember going down I spent
probably two or three hours in the sub
with with Stockton taking it through its
paces and and uh
you know I think like everybody I just
prayed right up until that conference
for yeah a miracle for a positive
outcome to all this uh Titanic film
director James Cameron currently
speaking to ABC News in America has just
said I'm struck by the similarity of the
Titanic disaster itself where the
captain was repeatedly warned about ice
ahead of his ship and yet he steamed at
full speed into an ice field
yeah I mean
listen this is a really difficult moment
I think for the families of these
individuals I I don't share some of the
viewpoints of your of um of the
gentleman Fred who was on a few moments
ago what I do share is this really
strong belief that the passengers aboard
Titan were incredibly uh courageous
individuals uh you know I've really been
sickened by so much of the especially on
social media so many people commenting
why would you do this why would you put
your life at risk to go down there and I
have to say that you know
um look Titanic has fascinated the world
since the night that she sank and it
holds a deep personal meaning for many
people shipwrecks in general as someone
who's visited many shipwrecks uh in my
career shipwrecks are time capsules they
connect us to the Past in a really
intimate way and there are people I mean
look at pH narjale his entire career had
been devoted after his work in the Navy
to studying Titanic and to being one of
the world's foremost experts on this
ship this is something that held great
meaning for these people and so uh you
know as someone who went in Titan and
and really didn't feel like I was
comfortable going down to those depths
in it I have to say it takes an enormous
amount of determination of Courage of
fortitude to take any trip inside a
submersible Titan or otherwise uh and so
I think there should be a huge amount of
admiration uh for all those people yeah
that's for Stockton I I have to say you
know I really really admire his vision I
admire his Spirit of innovation I admire
that he was a risk taker in some ways I
do think there are still really
important questions to ask not today but
soon uh about his calculations of risk
and acceptable risk and and again I
don't think that's something for today
but I I do think that he was an
innovator he was someone who was trying
to create a new
um a new platform uh that could open up
uh the depths of the ocean to to more
people uh I think that is a commendable
Noble aim I I think there are big
questions about how he got there and I
think that there'll be a time for that
but as for today I I just remain so
heartbroken for the families of these
people and for the passengers all of
them
um because I do think as an Explorer as
a guy who who understands people's
passions for things like this
um it was an admirable goal to go down
there and hey Miss Harding an
extraordinary guy he's a British
billionaire 58 years old he's chairman
of a dubai-based private plane firm
action Aviation but he holds three
Guinness world records including the
longest duration of full ocean depth by
crude vessel when he in March 2021 and
Ocean Explorer Victor vescovo dived to
the lowest part of the Mariana Trench he
was also Mission director and crew pilot
for the flight mission one more orbit
which set the current world speed record
for the fastest circumnavigation of
Earth by aircraft over both Geographic
poles I'm in a quite extraordinary
Adventurer and Explorer and you know are
there many people who are billionaires
who would risk everything to go down to
the bottom of the ocean to see the wreck
of the Titanic I doubt it and there are
so many Richard Branson's one that
brings to mind who who has done that
kind of thing but there are many most of
them Bank their cash and sit somewhere
you know surrounded by comfort and
security this guy risked his life and
yes he lost his life doing it but he was
in his bones an Explorer an adventurer a
risk taker probably made him the success
he was and I think that that's why I
totally concur with you that when people
ask why did they do this well why does
anyone do anything out of the ordinary
why does anyone go you know there are
people who who climb K2 right I'm not
going to climb K2 that's not for me but
I wouldn't say that someone was crazy to
do it because whether it's
mountaineering whether it's deep sea
exploration whether it's
you know anything if it holds great
personal meaning to you
then it's something that's admirable for
you to do you know and and so I I think
these people were incredibly Brave
Josh I really appreciate you joining me
thank you very much indeed
thank you pierce
well just to recap again uh the sound
breaking news that the Titan submersible
that vessel that had gone down at the
weekend to the wreckage of the Titanic
uh has now been confirmed to have
suffered a catastrophic implosion that
uh instantly believed instantly killed
all five passengers on board so an
extremely sad end to a story that has
really gripped the world in the last few
days
and they died
um as we were just discussing really in
heroic way you know on an adventure of a
lifetime an extraordinarily Intrepid and
risky Adventure they signed these
waivers that they knew meant they could
be going down to their death and that's
how this is this has transpired but I
suspect they would have no regrets for
having tried and that is the very nature
of explorers and adventurers but a sad
end to what has happened and yes there
will be questions asked of course there
will about how safe this vessel was
um you know one of the people who was
the founder of the company that made it
uh Stockton Rush he's died in this and
there will be serious questions to be
asked about whether it was really worthy
as a vessel to get that far down in the
ocean a very few vessels are where the
U.S military have submarines that cost
two billion dollars to go anywhere near
that kind of depth so that will be part
I'm sure of a big investigation into
this but let's not let the Twitter
trolls who in the last few days have
been mocking and taunting these people
not even knowing if they're Alive or
Dead uh claiming that because they have
money some of them somehow their lives
are less worthy and that we should be
focused on that rather than what they're
actually trying to do
I'm joined now by the former submarine
Commander uh don Walsh and by William
Conan who wrote a letter in 2018 raising
concerns about the safety of the Titans
sub so William Conan let me come to you
first we spoke about this yesterday
about this letter warning about issues
with the Titan submersible did people in
the in the industry old submersibles
believe that this was a disaster waiting
to happen
well look the uh thanks Piers for
inviting me again this is really hard
you know looking at all this and
listening to the Coast Guard uh
trying to find the feeling but I think
while you were speaking I think uh
heartbroken was one of the word that
comes comes to mind
um you know because we lose a colleague
in this industry we we know each other
well
the uh
look from the beginning uh we all felt
as experts in Industry that this was
extremely challenging
uh to put in context going 4 000 meters
with five people
requires a very large submersible and
first of all going to four thousand
meters is difficult going with five
people
space is difficult uh you know you'll
remember when Jim Cameron went right he
made himself a fairly small cabin he
learned how to sit in a crouched
position for a long time because the
smaller you make it the stronger you are
yeah a space is a luxury at these deep
depths and so it was our realization
that you're taking on a very challenging
issue that while we have been going down
to six thousand and seven thousand
meters
having a something as large as for five
people is uh is a is a big is a big
climb right there yeah yeah let me bring
in Don moose uh a legendary
oceanographer Don one of the first men
to reach the deepest point in the ocean
the Mariana Trench in 1960 uh you're one
of the first to reach that site you're a
former submarine Commander uh what is
your reaction to what's happened
well it's indeed tragic but um
frankly it was predictable as will Conan
will tell you we uh those of us have
been in this field and I've been in it
for six decades were concerned about
some of the engineering and operational
approaches that Ocean Gate was taking
towards developing building the
submarine now um there's nothing wrong
with you building experimental things uh
it's entirely on your own risk but were
you taking members of the public along
with you then it suddenly becomes a
concern to many regulatory authorities
now half century ago we we established
this community established uh
regulations for the construction
the design construction and maintenance
so man submersible these were done by
the so-called class classification
societies such as Lloyd's Register in
the UK and American where are shipping
us and so on and uh these uh
we often say most regulations or rules
are are Written in Blood because we
learn from accidents and such what uh we
should not have done and things that we
did not anticipate
so uh for a half century we've had these
rules and regulations but uh Ocean Gate
uh essentially decided not to follow
this type of guidance so those of us in
the keeps emergence Community led by
Will Conan uh wrote Stockton Rush a
letter expressing our concerns and
hoping that he would do more testing and
so on because the whole structure was
unproved and there's several other parts
of the sub that really needed more
testing so you know I hate to be a wet
blanket but you know that's the truth of
it I've I've been you know it's the
first submersible U.S Navy and probably
the second one the United States I've
piled a lot of submarines in the last
55 years so
um I
you have to say the truth uh and it's
it's uh it's something that's
uncomfortable but
um I think a lot of us felt it was not
yet but when I mean Don uh there's a
quote from James Cameron the Titanic
movie director you referenced earlier
who's just told ABC I'm struck by the
similarity of the Titanic disaster
itself where the captain was repeatedly
warned about ice ahead of his ship and
yet he steamed at full speed into an ice
field do you think that's a fair analogy
I do and uh I I I was with Jim on a one
Titanic expedition and by the way I've
made a dive to Titanic also back in
2005. and then I was on his sex
tradition when he was the second man
well the third man to dive to the
deepest place in the ocean Challenger
Deep so I you know I understand what
he's getting at and uh yeah I do uh I do
support that I mean it's there's certain
things that uh as I just said it's not
the question of if but when yeah and
again it's it's regrettable that members
of the public uh were exposed perhaps to
risk uh too early
uh don Walsh thank you very much indeed
for joining me and William Conan thank
you very much indeed for joining me
again I appreciate it
thank you
well again to bring you up to speed with
the breaking news which is that the
Titans submersible this vessel which has
gripped the attention of the world in
the last few days uh very sadly has been
confirmed suffered a catastrophic
implosion about 1600 feet away from the
wreck of the Titanic we don't know when
it happened it could have happened
pretty soon after they went down there
on Saturday uh nobody knows yet but we
do know that about 2 30 3 o'clock this
afternoon UK time just before nine
o'clock uh eastern time in America this
morning debris was discovered which gave
clear indication it had come from the
Titan submersible and the U.S Coast
Guard just before we came on air today
uh started a press conference in which
they confirmed that very sadly everybody
on board had lost those lives and we
should just remind ourselves I think
about the human beings here who have
died one was the CEO of the company that
put on the trip stopped him rush and
then there was a father and son Duo
shazada Darwin and his son Suleiman at
Darwood and Silliman was 19 years old a
student at strathclyde University in
Scotland and there was a British
billionaire Hamish Harding 58 who has
three Guinness World Records for his
exploration and Daredevil Feats over the
years A Man Who Loved adventure and
exploring and trying new things and
loved his history and Paul Omri najale
who was known as Mr Titanic he'd been
down more than 30 times to the wreck
he'd brought back a huge amount of
artifacts including chandeliers and so
on from the wreckage itself which he
gave to uh to to the world to know more
about that of course that moment when
the Titanic sank and one of the biggest
stories of of the history of planet
Earth these people shared a love of
exploring and adventure and I think that
there will be an investigation to what
happened but we should just salute their
courage in actually daring to do this
and I'd do that
well live coverage of this breaking
story will continue now with Rosanna
Lockwood on tour TV for the next few
hours stay with us but that's it from me
[Applause]
[Music]